foreign
this week on forward
what is the first lady of China doing
living in Berkeley California in the
middle of the second world war so I spun
this whole mystery out of that and I I
the part was really fun for me that was
more like being a lawyer is the research
that went into learning about the
history of the Bay Area during that time
I wrote that tiger mom Memoir the first
two thirds of it in three months it was
just supposed to be this fun thing my
younger daughter rebelled
um and honestly I just thought it was
gonna be funny
thank you
it is my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast yeah law professor multi-time
best-selling author public intellectual
and now novelist author of the brand new
novel The Golden Gate Amy Chua welcome
Amy thank you for having me Andrew
holy cow Amy I I've admired your work
for a long time I'm so glad now that uh
we we've actually gotten to know each
other in person in real life which is a
very exciting thing I know most people
when they hear your name and I hope this
doesn't you know surprise you at all
they might think who is that who is that
and then they think tiger mob
yep well I mean you have a very
multi-pronged Legacy which which we'll
get into for sure
um but were you surprised by what Accord
that book struck oh my gosh I was
completely unprepared and people don't
believe that you know I um this is now
like 11 no 12 years ago I bought that in
2011. and all my other books my foreign
policy books my books on political
tribalism
um
each of those books took me like three
or four years to write I wrote that
tiger mom Memoir the first two thirds of
it in three months it was just supposed
to be this fun thing my younger daughter
rebelled
um and honestly I just thought it was
gonna be funny
um and I think a lot of people didn't
quite realize it was even a whole book
you know it got excerpted the most um
provocative parts and I think a lot of
people just thought it was a Wall Street
Journal article they had slapped the
headline on it something like why
Chinese mothers are superior or
something yeah
um and it just uh triggered This Global
Firestorm and I didn't have social media
you know I mean I didn't have I had I
was completely unprepared for it I'd
never been on TV before
um so it was it was a crazy ride well
well certainly I remember that period
even even even that's like just a an
ordinary civilian being like huh and and
obviously uh being
um Asian American myself I was like oh
some of it felt familiar but to your
point I mean you've had a number of
major intellectual contributions over
the last number of years I I just picked
up at a random airport bookstore uh your
book on Triple Threat uh with your with
your husband Jed yeah um yeah triple
package thank you yeah uh why certain
groups seem to succeed at various levels
and I thought I read it and I thought to
myself wow this is very interesting and
provocative stuff
um and you've kind of made it a habit of
tackling things that other people shy
away from I suppose
like you're I feel like you're like a
commenter on unspoken truths yep you
know each of my books I actually don't
think that if you read it from cover to
cover should be controversial in any way
that book was called the triple package
um the rise and fall of cultural groups
in America and it does talk about how
and why
um certain groups at any given point in
history in the United States seem to be
outperforming others but like right off
the bat it says you know we figured out
that it's not genetic that it's nothing
static that anybody can access it so why
it kind of got taken to be controversial
the thesis of that book was that that
these three qualities in certain groups
the first is what we called uh maybe
provocatively a superiority complex
which is like a sense of being special
or a sense of exceptionalism
um like the Jews being the chosen people
or the Mormons or I don't know if you
ever got this like in a lot of Chinese
families there's a sense of we're from
the oldest civilization you know this
great uh Middle Kingdom but coupled with
that First Rate we discovered that a
second trait is indispensable and that's
seemingly the opposite and that is a
sense of deep insecurity
um and it's those two things combined
the sense of exceptionalism that you're
special in some way which a parent could
instill in you
um I remember Sonia Sotomayor told me
she identified with this
um but that coupled with insecurity is
what creates drive it makes people feel
you know
I'm not being respected enough I need to
show everybody and I I think that you'll
see that a lot of immigrants groups uh
tend to outperform other groups and
that's often because they are Outsiders
they have the sense of insecurity
um and the third trait is just um
impulse control which is kind of
self-discipline so yeah we had a with it
had a fun time with that book and it
applies to individuals and corporations
and universities
um not not just uh not just cultural
groups in America yeah I thought of it
as a chip on the shoulder
um yes
yeah yeah you do and uh reading the book
did feel familiar in various ways um I I
think that your observation that reading
a book cover to cover you're like sure
and then and then if you take out uh
this element or that element uh that
then uh you know it can become
sensationalized or overly dramatized I
think you were such a triple package
individual Andrew
I think you're a perfect example I mean
that in a really good way
well thank you I mean coming from you
that's the highest of compliments uh
also I I have
um met your daughters however briefly
and whatever you did seem to have worked
swimmingly so it should be very very
very proud I mean that they're uh
incredibly uh impressive individuals so
political tribes group Instinct and the
fate of Nations
um what what's fascinating here is that
you applied this both internationally
and domestically where you said look the
US seems to have these blind spots when
it comes to tribalism uh where
you think that people are going to see
things in ideological terms for example
capitalism versus communism or democracy
versus autocracy when really uh
typically as a sign is just made up of a
couple of tribes who may may or may not
like each other uh and one example is
sunnis and shias in a place like Iraq
and America seems to Omit that
particular Dynamic when it it comes and
has these large-scale interventions
sometimes uh unfortunately quite
tragically yeah you know I I actually
say that the reason for our biggest
foreign policy disasters in the last 50
years from Vietnam to Afghanistan to
Iraq all come from the fact that we know
so little about the group group dynamics
or the you know tribal affiliations that
matter most to the people that we're
supposedly trying to help
um and I this is an earlier book I wrote
world on fire but I did actually call
the Iraq dynamic Dynamic exactly
correctly a lot of people at that time
including friends of mine like Noah
Feldman said look we're going to put in
elections and the sunnis and shias and
you know with Kurds are all going to
come together and I was saying no
there's this concept of a market
dominant minority that is Ace when you
have a situation where a small
um you know group like say the sunnis
that are only about 14 of the population
are viewed as having controlled
Believers of power for so long economic
power maybe political power then if you
do overnight democracy majority rule can
actually be very destabilizing because
guess what suddenly given the vote the
new majority in this case the shias
they're not necessarily going to vote
for moderate you know friendly policies
but instead they're going to vote for
revenge and that's exactly what happened
um so I you know I said that's what
happened in Vietnam too and yeah so
that's the kind of international
component of it and I do apply that to
the United States as well
imagine running for president and
wanting to share what you experienced in
a way that's entertaining edifying and
maybe even a little bit scary that's the
last election out in bookstores now a
novel about Independent presidential
candidate a journalist with a massive
story and what the heck could be our
next slash last election check it out at
andrewyang.com
yeah domestically you said look hey the
educated Elite is Believe It or Not A
Tribe kind of you know maybe even takes
on various tribal uh instincts and
behaviors and that tribe facilitated uh
the rise of trump in in a way because it
has blind spots uh when it came to some
of Trump's appeal uh it there ended up
being this Us Versus Them Dynamic
um that continues to this day in many
ways
um and you see it where there are folks
who are of a particular uh educated
class who just don't seem to be able to
understand that folks of another class
or educational background might have a
completely different perspective and
that perspective may be something they
actually hold to very very strongly and
they they think is as legitimate
legitimate as your point of view uh and
you wrote this back in 28 teen how have
things played out since then and what
was the your the reaction to your
argument yeah you know Andrew this is
where your your projects and your work
and your party are so aligned I mean
just coincidentally
um back in 2018 so I was actually one of
the people that uh uh predicted the
Trump election and
um you know Yale law school is it's an
amazing place that people are brilliant
and very much at the time involved with
Hillary Clinton's campaign but I could
see at the time that there were some
serious blind spots
um and as we now all know you know those
very States like Pence whatever
Pennsylvania Michigan Wisconsin
um that that whole block of uh states
that um uh you know the Democrats
weren't really paying attention to they
actually went to Donald Trump that year
and so it's very similar to what I was
talking about with developing countries
um one of the things I say in my books
is that the United States we've had a
lot of problems but we've never had this
problem of a market dominant minority
that is a a little ethnic group like the
Chinese in Indonesia or the whites in
South Africa or even the lighter-skinned
europeanized Elites in Venezuela that
are viewed as controlling the economy
and being very arrogant and insular and
not caring about the rest of the country
um you know the United States we've
always just had a lot of mobility and
there's no one ethnic group not Asians
not Jews they they may be
disproportionately successful but they
don't actually control 70 of the economy
but what I wrote in this recent book is
that I'm worried that just in the last
five to ten years we're seeing the
emergence of our own very idiosyncratic
form of a market dominant minority in
the United States and this is the group
that you refer to that sometimes called
Cosmopolitan Elite sometimes called
Coastal Elites
and the irony is this is these are all
my friends I'm in this category myself
you know I think people who teach at
Columbia or NYU or Harvard or Yale or
work on Wall Street or Hollywood you
know a lot of central figures in DC we
view ourselves as so tolerant and
open-minded and Cosmopolitan the you
know it's it's the other side that's
intolerant
um and one of the provocative things I
say in political tribes is we don't
realize how you know post Elites don't
realize how insular and actually
um uh perceived as arrogant they they
come off us to the rest of the country
you know
um Coastal Elites they actually pretty
much you know they don't they're not an
ethnic group but they dress very
similarly they send their kids to the
same schools they eat the same Foods
they like the same Aesthetics they
vacation in the same place is and it is
in fact this is something that you've
really
you know been so important and um it is
in fact the case that wealth in this
country is incredibly concentrated on
our two posts uh and and Coast Elites do
actually Dominate and control many of
the same sectors that market dominant
minorities like the Chinese in the
Philippines or the Lebanese and West
Africa control for example Wall Street
or Silicon Valley the ivy league uh you
know uh I mean just you know Washington
in many ways so so yes what I predicted
in that book was that I actually
predicted that we were going to see in
the election of 2016 uh the rise of
demagogues that would actually play on
this and say Hey you know this country
is being controlled by a small number of
people live on the coast who don't care
about Real Americans so we need to make
America great again we need to take back
the country and that kind of rhetoric is
something that we've seen actually more
commonly in developing countries like
Robert agave in Zimbabwe or Hugo Chavez
and in Venezuela so the thesis of
political tribalism was a little scary
it was that for the first time in all of
U.S history we're starting to see
um just certain very specific kinds of
destructive ethno and ethno-nationalist
kinds of political dynamics that are
much more common in developing countries
than you know previously the United
States do you know Barbara Walter the
political scientist she wrote something
similar uh in her book I think it was
called how Civil Wars start I've heard
of it haven't read it yet no you guys
would probably get along but see what
she did is she went into various
developing countries and she saw these
patterns that you're describing and
there was a very consistent pattern
around someone appealing to nativism and
a certain group that I think even had a
technical term I think it was called oh
my gosh Barbara I'm sorry I'm going to
mess this up but it's uh I I think it
was something like Children of the Earth
or something very very specific sounding
but you read it and I was like Children
of the Earth or whatever the heck it was
do you know what I'm talking about yes I
think that sons of the soil it is
something like that sounds of the soil
that was it thank you baby snugs of the
soil yeah in Malaysia because the idea
is like we're the real people we're the
people who were originally here and you
know in a funny way president Donald
Trump's kind of make America great again
let's take back our country away from
you know the the the Chinese and the
Mexicans um it is tapping into a similar
Dynamic like this idea that there are
Real Americans um who are you know and a
lot of was very effective actually in
this country saying you know what these
Elites they care more about the poor in
Africa
um the Richmond north of Richmond song I
mean you hear that you see that yes I
think yes absolutely it strikes the same
chord though he himself is not you know
he wants nothing to do with the uh
tribalism
yeah totally
um but of course you know America being
what it is today
um once I tried to claim it
um and I'm happy to say at least like
some people on the other side saw it as
what it was which struck me as just a
deep uh popular appeal which is look man
I mean you know things aren't going our
way
and the then the natural thing is to
blame someone and so the the image of
Richmond north of Richmond was very
evocative yeah totally and he wasn't
like some famous pop singer I mean I you
know I watched him many times he really
sounds like an authentic guy you know
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang of new
guests thank you
so you've taught some folks uh who've
gone on to become a very very uh
prominent figures in various ways and I
just had a question for you um so I I
was at a party and then someone came up
to me
um who I Knew by reputation and they
knew me by reputation and they said to
me hey
um like I I don't know you I just know
all of like the stuff I've seen from and
about you in various media but I tend to
throw all that stuff out because I I
know the media is just a bunch of like
distortions and fun house mirrors so
very pleased to meet you and just want
to be able to to meet you as an actual
human
um yeah I know it was very I was like oh
thank you I mean it did make me think
it's like oh like uh like uh
like like what do you what are you
ignoring here but yeah I've been there
yeah we could talk about that
um but but for you you must have at this
point half a dozen to a dozen former
students who are in the public eye in
various ways and then people probably
come to you and figure hey what's up
with this person what's up with that
person uh how much does the depiction in
the media line up with the human being
or not line up in your experience pretty
terribly honestly
like you know I'm really proud of
um of my students who range from extreme
left to extreme right so just give you
two examples uh Ronan Farrow who broke
the whole metoo movement wasn't a former
student and pretty much wrote Every
paper with me and we were always very
close
um and as everybody knows uh JD Vance at
the other uh extreme author of hillbilly
elegy was also my student and we're also
very close and I it's so funny like I
remember both those guys as people who
were just lost and that's why they came
to me I tend to Mentor people who are a
little bit Outsiders probably just
because if we want yeah you know I think
I any kind of Outsider I mean there's so
many ways of being an outsider and you
and um JD just honestly now gosh she's a
senator and there's so much stuff about
him and it's unrecognizable for me like
I remember him he came and he kind of
stuck out he was dressed differently
than everybody else to sound a little
different was unusually tall
um and I remember in the first week of
school he he was practically want to
drop out he just felt like everything he
said uh just sounded stupid and we
really bonded at one point he was he
really was gonna drop out it was
actually what his girlfriend
um now wife wanted to take a break and
he's like I you know so I just think of
these guys as just sincere authentic
real warm people
um and now that they're so successful I
see what I read about them in the Press
is it's totally a caricature first of
all again if you you know literally take
every single thing these people have
said it would not add up to that and
same with Ronan Pharaoh he came in very
young
uh he went to Bard so I think he was
like 16 or something when he started law
school and you know
he was seriously maybe I was 18. but he
had skipped all these years he was like
a prodigy and absolutely brilliant but
same thing like now he's such a
celebrity and you know does these
amazing things but at the time he was a
little bit of a misfit he had had he
came in in crutches because he had had
some something happened in when he was
in Africa so his first day of school
he's five years younger than everybody
else and he comes in on two crutches and
um so I remember these people warmly and
we're still friends we're still friends
um uh you know Vivek ramaswamy is
another one I didn't teach him but he's
another one of our former students that
we're close to so I try to keep the
politics out of it every time something
comes up I'm the Press calls me and asks
me to denounce these people or you know
um and I just I just won't do it you
know I think that makes some people mad
but um but it's just it's just my Paul
LLC I'm not going to ever trash talk any
former students
I I would say it's a fine policy myself
I mean it would allow folks to actually
get to know you as their professor and
Mentor without thinking years later
they're gonna
uh it's one of the best parts of my job
I'm not like a great legal theorist but
I do love mentoring people who feel like
they might want to drop out of law
school because that's kind of how I felt
well well my big jam is trying to talk
people out of going to law school
um
though you know Yale is somewhat special
I mean there's a joke in legal circles
that you know if you don't want to
actually be a lawyer go to Yale uh you
know there is some truth to that I mean
if you could actually get in which I did
not
um so
so I I had a a question on on this like
there was like a very very strange
controversy at Yale around your
mentoring students like there's
something where it somehow got painted
in negative light and to this day like I
just remember this what struck me
frankly as a bit of a smear job
um that didn't fully make sense
but but it be one reason why if you or
you like your natural explanation is
like look I'm not gonna like join in a
pylon because uh I I think you might
have actually experienced a pylon
yourself for some reason oh completely
now anytime it's human nature I'll read
about anybody you know Kate Middleton or
or just anything it's your natural
instinct is like it's just fun to gossip
and to imagine the worst but I have so
changed like I just take everything with
a grain of salt no matter what it is
um that thing was oh gosh it was like
three years ago when it blew over I
think it was called dinner party date or
something and it was in the middle of
covid and honestly Andrew now I think
that a lot of it had to do with the
pandemic people were cooped up it was
the first year where students instead of
the first year students getting to meet
in small groups and have picnics and go
out everybody was on zoom and so you
know you couldn't make friends you
couldn't really meet your professors in
uh in person and somehow this rumor
started that I was having dinner parties
with I think federal judges and a secret
group of students drunken dinner parties
this was so crazy it was so surreal it
was it was literally kafka-esque
um
but and I was very upset at the time and
I it got covered because of who I am it
was like how is this stupid thing why
does that make the New Yorker and the
New York Times you know
um but in the end I kind of believe in
the system I mean I I feel like I was
Vindicated you have University looked
into it thoroughly and found absolutely
no basis for any of these crazy things
and everything's back to normal now you
know and I love my students I have these
giant classes so you know if you just
this is the tiger uh parenting part you
know my parents the one thing is they
said just push through just don't give
up just push through it'll get better
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn is
like not paying attention to the safety
demonstration on a flight most of the
time you'll probably be fine but what if
one day that weird yellow mask drops
down from overhead and you have no idea
what to do it's better to be safe than
sorry that's why I recommend using
expressvpn the network that's used by
high-end corporations for their remote
workers so that everything they do is
hacker proof Anonymous and verified I
like expressvpn because it's easy to use
one click and you're done and you can
access content that you might not be
able to see otherwise from Europe on
Netflix and other providers to cure your
online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com Yang that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang and you can get an extra
three months free
expressvpn.com yang
so we have something else in common
though you're better at
um probably both of them but after
writing five non-fiction books some of
which were International bestsellers now
you've written your first novel
you're so much more exciting
well mine is darker though yours again
yeah my my mine's a little bit more oh
it's so relevant no no mine's
straightforward whereas yours is
actually literary
it's like oh wow Amy wrote like a piece
of literature which I found very very
impressive and sophisticated thank you I
you know I um I don't think people knew
this about me but when I was little I uh
well you know I had very strict parents
and so we weren't allowed a huge amount
of social Freedom so I was a huge
Bookworm my favorite thing was to go to
the public library I went to Public
Schools Carrie Hub all these books and
they were actually always novels and in
particular always murder mysteries you
know I read every single Agatha Christie
um so it was my first love and I tried
to write a a novel uh what I was trying
to get out of Wall Street this is to
your point I I graduated from law school
and I was like why did I do this I found
myself in corporate law not good at it
bored by it but also just not talented
at it so I tried to write a novel back
then and I couldn't quite pull it
together
um and yes it was actually during covert
that I finally had time a plot just hit
me
um and it's so funny under the
coincidence right because we were
thinking about the political tribalism
issues at exactly the same time I still
remember getting an email from you right
around
2016-17 uh or maybe 2015 thinking about
the same issues and then when I found
out that your novel that you wrote had
written a novel and that it's coming out
a week before mine I'm like this guy's
always ahead of me
or we're just on the same wavelength
so this plot hit you during covid uh
again I think it's a very impressive
sophisticated uh piece of literature and
I you know I I use that term
deliberately
um but it interweaves uh family
geopolitics race California history
um and it that there are they're very
um timely themes around uh I suppose
like a country that is
um in the throes of a conflict and thus
uh has some
um mistreatment of various uh groups
within it
um which unfortunately is something that
we kind of sense like might become
relevant
today uh so so in your case
um you got hit by this plot uh how did
you go about saying you know what I'm
actually going to to write this novel
there's a lot of research involved in
your novel clearly yes and lawyer stuff
so the book is a historical murder
Thriller set in the San Francisco Bay
area in 1944.
um and the book opens with a grandmother
from one of San Francisco's oldest
families being told by the district
attorney that one of her three
granddaughters is a murderer and they
don't know which one so that's the thing
that hit me I came up with this idea of
a grandmother who's told that one of her
three
um granddaughters is the murder and I
kind of thought of the twist which I
won't give away a bunch of twists
um and then I was actually in my parents
house so so I actually you know my
parents are American dream exemplars
like I grew up in a very small house in
a place called El Cerrito in the Bay
Area area I went to public high schools
but by the time I went to college my
parents had moved to another house in
the Berkeley Hills and it turns out that
that house was where Madame Chiang
Kai-shek the former first lady of China
lived in 1943 to 1944 for reasons to
this day nobody knows what is the first
lady of China doing living in Berkeley
California in the middle of the second
world war so I spun this whole mystery
out of that and I I the part that was
really fun for me that was more like
being a lawyer is the research that went
into learning about the history of the
Bay Area during that time so obviously
it was the time of the Japanese
internment which I think has you know in
some ways a lot of parallels to our to
today there was a lot of class conflict
there were a lot of poor whites that had
come from the Dust Bowl
African-Americans actually came in for
the first time I did not know that uh to
to build these ships all these shipyards
because after Pearl Harbor uh we didn't
have a Navy anymore so the Bay Area was
transformed into literally the largest
shipbuilding Center in in history and I
never knew any of this going up in the
Bay Area
just about 20 years before that they had
deported forcibly deported you know
maybe a million um people back to Mexico
so there were just a lot of themes that
are parallel in some ways to what's
happening in America right now but you
know because it was as it was a long
time ago it was just easier and more
less less stressful to write about it
it's it's a backdrop that raises a lot
of the same issues that we have today
but first and foremost it's supposed to
be an entertaining Thriller you know a
big who done it well it succeeds on uh
the level of entertainment and I learned
a lot uh you know that my my parents met
at UC Berkeley uh in the 60s
um and and so and my brother's named
after the Lawrence Hall of Science
um so so we we joke my parents got busy
there though I'm sure they didn't
um but oh when everywhere in town we
bring my kids to the Lawrence Hall of
Science and be like look you know I
think this is your uncle's named after
um so I I felt a little bit of a kinship
with the
um some of the historical events even
though my parents got there later
yeah did you know that Berkeley so
famously liberal right now but that
whole neighborhood and I think they
might still exist today
um all of the houses have these racial
covenants in them
um so somebody had to intervene like
technically no Chinese people no
non-whites could live in Berkeley it's
certainly in the Berkeley Hills and
Madame Chiang kishek had to get some
rich Banker friend from Wells Fargo to
help so so if there's just a lot of um
real and all these interesting
characters too
um there's this woman named mom Chung
and how could I not know this right
she's like the first chinese-american uh
woman doctor in the United States and
she was such a character she would have
these soires
um that John Wayne and Ronald Reagan and
all these Hollywood stars would come and
she was probably lesbian you know she
she dressed like a man and um never
married at her funeral Admiral Nimitz
was one of her pallbearers like it's
like this crazy celebrity figure who
lived in San Francisco and was years
ahead of her time attended a lot of
Bohemian nightclubs so it was fun
learning about people like her and this
guy August Vollmer who again from
Berkeley California he was the founder
of American policing you know all these
things that we teach people in law
school you know all the techniques
finger printing and two-way mirrors or
one-way mirrors all of that was in
Berkeley California like up the street
from where my parents live so that was a
really fun piece of you know research
and investigative work
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like
five percent of people do the math for a
hundred night free trial you can sleep
on this thing for three months it will
keep you cool don't just take my word
for it my kids seek out this mattress in
the house it's the number one rated
mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine
this mattress will actually make you
happier healthier and more productive
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now
so after you finish the novel actually
and you know this is just an insidery
thing maybe but it might be interesting
um so you're known for writing uh
best-selling non-fiction books
um how did your agent respond to the
fact hey I've got a novel and then
what was it and and do you feel too and
this is one of the jokes I told I was at
a party with some famous people
um and there was a a person who had
their first book coming out and I said
you know what you can't get away with
saying hey I wrote this book and it's
just a casual thing and you know we
should check it out because because like
a book actually takes like a significant
investment uh of of time and energy it
becomes personal pretty quickly uh and
so for you is there like some uh
nervousness around this being your first
foray into fiction like do you have
other stories that have hit you even
since the time that you finished this
book because that does happen to my
creative and novelist friends where they
all all of a sudden start getting being
pelted with new stories and characters
yeah well first of all my agent
basically punted me she was like I don't
represent what you know what are you
doing now um and she introduced me to a
different agent so I'm represented by
somebody different for just for this
novel and yes I'm terrified and I
actually don't have like
I'm not gosh maybe this is defensive but
I'm I don't have
um
crazy expectations I felt like I wanted
to prove it to myself I I wanted to make
it all work so as you know writing a
thriller it has to come together like
you can't cheat like you have to make a
timeline the facts have to fit together
and especially if it's like a mystery
when you reveal it you know your readers
are going to be mad if the clues aren't
all there like it has to it has to be
plausible but you also have to keep it
from the readers so for me a lot of the
analytics was very similar in some ways
to being a lawyer like I how do I um
keep everything straight but also hide
the ball but piece it all together like
a puzzle so on that part I really liked
I mostly just want this to be a really
fast-paced fun talk about fast paced I I
could not put your book down I was just
flipping that that takes skill um and so
I would like to try to write a different
one I do have an idea but I don't want
to get ahead of myself like you know
let's see what happens to this one first
um that is one of the things that
happens to us it was the same way it's
like I'm like oh I kind of like to do
something else in this space like I have
to wait and see what what what what
happens with this one though as you say
it out loud I think the Golden Gate
would make a fantastic uh mini series
uh limited series because it is very
very
intricately plotted and smart your I
mean people probably can tell I mean
you're you're a brilliant human and a
brilliant writer and having uh that
intellect applied to plotting uh was
something of a joy just because one of
the most frustrating things is when it
doesn't hold up
you know it's like
um the so sorry anyone who's associated
with this but like certain TV shows pop
to mind for me where it's like you know
that that TV show didn't hold up uh down
the stretch and then yeah
or the Killer is somebody that you just
meet at the last second like that's not
fair you know if it's like a big mystery
thing you're wondering which of the 10
people did it it can't just be a
stranger off the street that comes on at
the last second so but yeah it has to it
has to land and the great thing for you
for for the reader uh with with your
book is you actually feel like you're in
good hands
like that that uh
um sense of being cheated what you get
when like it it doesn't hold up and in
your case it holds up so my agents I
have really good agents and um this was
uh so this took me you know during
kovitch right like maybe two years but
at one point I um I turn in this
manuscript and they gave me all these
great comments about what didn't work so
then I you know being myself worked
really really hard and you know set back
something you know like a month later
um there was a long silence and then my
agent called me and said okay we read
this and um you've made it worse
and they're like you are you know uh you
always we like you a lot but you always
have to be that a student and Fiction's
a little different sometimes you need to
let it percolate and think and let
yourself be artistic so why Agent
actually said I'm not on the next round
I'm not going to read this for eight
months oh my God Andrew this almost
killed me but I'm so impatient she's
like I really want you to think about
this and so so the process was a
learning one for me too like then I
she's like I want you to read some
novels and just like you know switch
your mentality away from foreign policy
books um so it worked in the end but I I
had to have a I I made a lot of mistakes
and I got some I got some good help well
I dare say Amy I think you might have
unlocked a different part of your brain
and I I for one hope that that continues
that that part of your brain actually
gives rise to more intelligent
well-crafted stories filled with vibrant
character years of now like I actually
would love to see uh the Golden Gate
miniseries uh and I can imagine
um various actors running for various
parts it'd be great
um and and it is like a different
journey I will say I'm like my side I
mean I had a co-author who's who went
through a lot of the
um process and pains that that you're
describing so I cannot lay claim to have
gone through the the similar process but
it really is such a different
take a different writing style and and
because of the different writing style
it's like a different brain wiring uh
and yeah and and so for like I just give
you so much credit for uh accessing new
brain wiring in this way
I mean
it's it does you're right you have to
brain right because you're I I keep
wanting to um I don't know like I it's
weird in a way if you get good at this
you're much more freedom in writing
fiction like you could just invent but
you know at the very beginning I had to
draw on autobiographical things or
people I know like it's actually really
a challenge just to invent a character
out of out of nothing you know so um so
yeah I think we probably went through a
lot of the same learning curve you know
what's funny is when you write
nonfiction you're you're always
fastidious about like well like have to
make sure that's factually accurate have
to make sure this and then the fictional
element is like we'll have to make sure
this person seems real and like in that
whatever detail I include is actually
pretty accurate and the easiest way to
do that is to base it on an actual human
and you can just point to that person
and be like no look like they're they're
right there you better pick an
interesting one
well people should definitely check out
the Golden Gate if they are into any
form of fiction uh particularly murder
mysteries uh how can people keep up with
you and your work Amy because you're a
bit of a polymath and you you cover lots
of different areas
well maybe I'll see you on book tour I
mean I'm going to be doing I'm going on
my three week book tour and people could
always pick it up on Amazon or oh my
website amychua.com
um and yeah you know it's really fun I
hope I hope you and I end up on the same
maybe we'll
see each other because our books are
coming out almost the exact same time
uh Amy I'll make a point of it I'm gonna
show up to one of your events and then
have you sign a copy
um for for me and Evelyn Amy chua.com
the Golden Gate the novel you can check
out all of our other books too
um because she's a brilliant woman with
a whole lot of insight to offer on the
world whether it's fiction or
non-fiction Amy uh please keep us posted
and I can't wait to see what you do next
thank you Andrew you're an inspiration
and a good friend and good luck with
your book too thanks for having me
thank you